Jason Momoa and ASA Gonzalez Calling it
Quits with the onset of Summer marking
an end to their Romance
trying to be a gentleman E.T confirmed
the two were dating last month and now
we're learning the relationship was
always pretty casual The Source explains
they're both busy with work commitments
and their own lives Jason is very
focused on his career right now they
realize they're both different and
looking for different things
this Echoes what E.T learned about the
relationship in May with another source
revealing quote Jason and Asia started
as friends but always had an underlying
chemistry and things are casual between
them and although it's not clear if they
were dating at the time in April Jason
attended the red carpet of aza's movie
ambulance well I can't say it'll ruin it
man when it comes to A's dating history
the actress had a romance with Josh
dumel that ended in 2018 and shortly
after she was romantically linked to
Timothy chalamet after the pair were
spotted kissing is it dating Jason
follows his split from Lisa Bonet after
the pair announced they were going their
separate ways in January at the time the
Aquaman star took to Instagram to
announce the news of their separation
writing quote we have all felt the
squeeze and changes that these
transformational times A revolution is
unfolded and our families of no
exception feeling and growing from the
seismic shifts occurring and so we share
our family news that we are parting ways
in marriage
shortly after Jason broke the news A
source told E.T that the pair had been
struggling in their relationship for
quite some time and when Jason was away
filming Aquaman 2 their differences and
issues were heightened he was gone for a
while and it definitely put additional
stress on their relationship and Insider
revealed that Mamoa and Bonet still have
love for each other and respect one
another which Jason who shares 14 year
old Lola and 13 year old nicoa wolf with
Lisa made clear in March when he along
with their two kids stepped out to
support Lisa's daughter Zoe Kravitz at
the premiere of the Batman in New York
City we're just so proud you know Lenny
can be here a little quick you know Lisa
couldn't be here so we're representing
me and the babies and so we're very
excited to
just be here
[Music]